the Soviet Civil War existing as one of
Marvel's most revered events taking
place in the mid-2000s this story goes
hand-in-hand with the death of Captain
America which actually brings a Civil
War conflict to a close in a 2007
interview with coming up with resources
writer Edie Brubaker had stated that
when he was brought on board to write
for Captain America with volume 5 Steve
Rogers death at the hands of the Red
Skull was actually something that he had
planned all along
however because Civil War was close to
release with the ending somewhat ironed
out but not set in stone
he was forced to move up his timetable
regarding the return of the Red Skull
and the assassination of Captain America
to this end editor Baker introduced
several characters that would play a key
role in this story the first of these
and perhaps the most important was Bucky
Barnes having been written out of
continuity at the close of the original
Captain America comics in the 1950s
Marvel's explanation for a lack of Bucky
Barnes following the rediscovery of
Captain America in the 1960s was the
Bucky Barnes had simply been killed and
so using this as a jumping-off platform
a true Baker wreck on the history and
stating that the Russians following his
presumed death had actually taken Bucky
with his memories wiped he was
transformed into the Winter Soldier
operating behind the scenes under the
control of KGB director aleksandr Lucan
bringing the red skull in as part of the
story's buildup Bucky Barnes was tasked
with assassinating the Red Skull and
retrieving his Cosmic Cube under Lukens
orders while succeeding and collecting
the cube the Red Skull had actually used
his power to transfer his mind to the
body of Alexander Lucan in order to
stave off death as we discussed in my
video on the Winter Soldier the story
progressed in a manner that saw the cube
fall into Captain America's possession
using his power during the fight the
Bucky was able to regain control of
himself but went into hiding in order to
come to terms with his past actions
the next question I'd like to draw your
attention to is Sharon Carter as the
niece of Peggy Carter the former love
interest of Steve Rogers during World
War two the share had spent most of her
youth regaled by Iran with hails of both
her own exploits as well as the
greatness of Captain America looking to
follow in the steps of Peggy Sheridan
listed with shield and while her initial
appearance came in tales of suspense
issue number 65 it wouldn't be until
issue number 85 that she would actually
meet Captain America for the first time
and after being rescued by Steve Rogers
from a small-time villain named Batroc
the leaper Sharon Carter immediately
became enamored with Captain America and
as her care to progress to Marvel's
continuity a romance formed between the
two of them now this is something I'd
like you to keep in the back of your
head because the romance between Captain
America and Sharon Carter will actually
be a very significant aspect of Steve
Rogers death having said all of that
with civil war playing out as the battle
ground between Captain America's Secret
Avengers and Iron Man's registered
Avengers ending with Captain America's
surrender to authorities and Brubaker
began to set his plan in motion by
bringing together crossbones Bucky
Barnes Red Skull dr. Foster's who is a
master of hypnotism Sharon Carter and
Nick Fury for the story of death of a
dream the death of Captain America
so following the arrest of Steve Rogers
at the conclusion of civil war for
failing to register in addition to
inciting treason and Sedition against
the United States we pick up with Bucky
Barnes following his return operating
alongside Nick Fury who is currently in
an undisclosed location due to having
learned about the events that would lead
into the secret invasion storyline while
it's a little ambiguous here the idea
seems to be that Nick Fury Bucky Barnes
and Xuan Carter are planning an escape
for Steve Rogers however once Captain
America arrives we find that he is the
subject of both be vile and praise from
the protesters outside of the courthouse
with some throwing food at him but
others praising his stance the public's
response is a result of both their
disdain for Steve Rogers actions and
standing against America but also in
support of his willingness to stand up
for what he believed to be right
however as the US Marshals are leading
him up the steps Steve Rogers realizes
that there is a sniper in a window
taking aim at him but from here we
transitioned to dr. FASTA sand red skull
in the body of Alexander Lucan with the
coverage of Captain America's trial
broadcast on all the news stations both
men are watching the events unfold
realizing that Captain America has
spotted the sniper the immediate
reaction by dr. fauci's is to call off
the plan however as red skull states
this is the plan with Steve Rogers and
handcuffs and unable to protect himself
than with both dr. Fausta's and the Red
Skull using their sources to ensure that
Steve Rogers ends up at the federal
courthouse and Captain America has been
put in a position where he is virtually
powerless against whoever plans to shoot
him
with a sniper opening fire the scene is
met with immediate panic from the
onlookers as well as Sharon Carter and
Bucky leaping into action however where
Sharon Carter arrives at Steve Rogers
location it's revealed that he had
sustained a gunshot wound to the stomach
I'm pleading with Sharon Carter to
ensure that civilians aren't injured and
to get them out of harm's way
he simply collapses now we're showing
Carter went to the aid of Steve Rogers
Bucky Barnes alongside Falcon attempt to
locate the sniper after arriving in the
room where the shot originated Bucky
finds a shooter had vacated
however because Falcon was unaware of
Bucky's return and because their last
meeting took place during a fight with
Captain America and Falcon initially
believes that Bucky is the triggerman
but once cooler has prevailed the two
men realized that the real shooter has
gotten
a taking to the air Buckey states that
according to Nick Fury one of the
helicopters is masquerading as a news
helicopter and that it is swooped in to
grab the shooter at this point we
learned that these sniper is actually
blocked from low and as Bucky Barnes
shoots out the tail of the helicopter
crossbones leaps into Bucky and Falcon
in order to both cushion his fall as
well as engage both men now a Bucky's
prodigious skill as a fighter allows him
to subdue crossbones almost immediately
because he was underground during the
entire Civil War conflict and is
considered an unregistered hero Falcon
advises him to simply leave before being
captured by shield and taking the advice
Bucky simply departs to go back
underground again now at this point we
switch back to Captain America as he's
being transported to the hospital with
Sharon Carter Etta sighs Steve Rogers is
able to mumble a few words regarding his
love for her but as we transition away
is revealed to us by way of a news
broadcast that Steve Rogers had actually
died on his way to the hospital at this
point we transition to Sharon Carter
following Captain America's arrival and
the subsequent attempts to resuscitate
him while trying to clear her head and
cope with the loss Sharon Carter is met
by a woman named sin as a daughter of
the Red Skull sin is extremely minor in
this story with this being her only
major role but after approaching Sharon
she states that dr. Foster says to
remember and so where you may have
noticed that this story seemed a little
ambiguous up until this point what we're
going to do is provide the flashback
offered in this narrative as well as
grab some information from other sources
to paint a more complete picture as is
revealed to us in Captain America vol 5
issue number 22 it was shown that dr.
fauci's had been working as a
psychiatrist for shield while employing
technology allowing him to change his
appearance as one of Captain America's
oldest enemies dr. Foster's working
alongside the red skull had been
hypnotizing Sharon Carter into falling
in love with Steve Rogers the using this
as a way in faucets and Red Skull began
plotting their assassination with a
civil war van distracting Captain
America Red Skull and dr. fauci's
employed Brock twemlow operating as a
sniper at the courthouse Brock rumlow
fired a shot in the shoulder of Captain
America and while it did hit its mark
this function strictly as a distraction
under the hypnotic control of dr. Faust
Asst Sharon Carter approached Captain
America with a pistol and fired the
killing shot and so as a gravity of the
situation begins to come into full view
we find that Sharon Carter is left with
the realization that she had killed
Captain America so following the death
of Captain America the story proved
itself to be a monumental success coming
in at 290 thousand issues sold making it
the highest selling comic for the month
of March in addition to this as a
mainstay character from Marvel the death
of Captain America received national and
even international attention while
various interviews from news outlets
regarding fan reaction fell in the
direction of some fans believing it was
time for Captain America to go while
others hated the decision the problem
here was that the story couldn't simply
stop with Sharon Carter shooting Steve
Rogers in order to wrap up the narrative
that had been started Ed Brubaker
released two other segments - the death
of Captain America titled the burden of
Dreams and the man who bought America
while both stories were considered a bit
lackluster compared to the events
preceding them the burden of Dreams saw
Marvel introducing Bucky Barnes as the
new Captain America something that was
highly anticipated by fans following
Steve Rogers death furthermore under Jim
flow the death of Captain America events
saw Marvel publishing 5 tie-in stories
under the mantle of fallen son each
story dealt with the five stages of
grief denial anger bargaining depression
and acceptance with each story following
Bucky Barnes will reign Hawkeye
spider-man and finally the combination
of superheroes and America as Captain
America's funeral is held which contain
another iconic scene depicting Tony
Stark by the side of Steve Rogers corpse
saying his farewells
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it and I will catch you guys
later peace